muss man möglicherweise die bußgelder
auch erhöhen das sind jetzt diskussionen
die schon stattgefunden haben nach den
demonstrationen müssen kontrollen
verstärkt werden und bußgelder erhöht
werden also muss der druck auch noch mal
erhöht werden bei bislang wird ja auch
sehr sehr viel an den guten willen
appelliert an die vernunft und an die
eigenverantwortung
ich glaube wir brauchen beides einmal
das verständnis noch mal deutlich zu
machen wie wichtig es ist solidarisch zu
sein in unserer gesellschaft dürfe nicht
vergessen ganz viele menschen stehen
unter einem erheblichen risiko sich zu
infizieren
daran ernsthaft zu erkranken oder gar zu
sterben auch das verlangt solidarität
eigentlich alle
und wer sich nicht daran hält der muss
auch mit einem empfindlichen bußgeld
recht und ich glaube schon dass man da
noch mal eine schippe drauf legen müsste
beim bußgeld wir müssen aber auch
schauen wie kannst du solchen
situationen kommen wir haben den letzten
monaten auch einen
überbietungswettbewerb aller 16
ministerpräsidenten oder präsidentinnen
gehabt in deutschland mit den
lockerungen und aus den lockerungen der
regierung ist sehr häufig eine
allgemeine lockerheit in der bevölkerung
geworden und deswegen der appell an alle
die lage ist nach wie vor ernst und
vorsicht ist immer noch das beste gebot
der stunde